[Musica]
vorrei iniziare con una domanda per
trovare grandi quantità di oro dove lo
andreste a cercare
probabilmente molti di voi risponderanno
forse la cosa migliore da fare e andarlo
a cercare in qualche miniera
bisogna rimboccarsi le maniche e
mettersi a scavare nel buio e con una
buona dose di fortuna
troveremo loro ora io non posso
definirmi un minatore visto che non ho
mai preso in mano un piccone non sono
neanche mai stato in una miniera
eppure sappiate che con un gruppo di
miei colleghi provenienti un po da tutto
il mondo proprio cercando nel buio
abbiamo localizzato la più grande e il
più grande giacimento di oro mai
scoperto una riserva pari a qualcosa
come 100 mila miliardi di miliardi di
tonnellate g t g meno se lo mettessimo
tutto sul mercato loro sarebbe così
abbondante da arrivare a costare molto
meno dell'acqua
come è possibile
la facciamo prima un passo indietro in
realtà io non sono qui per parlare di
spedizioni leggendarie tra le viscere
della terra
io sono qui per parlare di esplorazione
del cosmo di astrofisica e in
particolare di qualcosa che almeno per
noi ricercatori è ben più prezioso
dell'oro ovvero un tipo di stelle o
corpi celesti piuttosto particolari
chiamati stelle di neutroni che sono
anche le protagoniste di una recente
scoperta estremamente importante le
stelle di neutroni in un certo senso
nascono dalla morte di una stella di
grande massa queste stelle concludono la
loro vita in modo violento con
un'esplosione violenta che nota come
supernova forse avete sentito questo
nome è un fenomeno davvero spettacolare
che osserviamo di tanto in tanto
cosa succede quando arriva alla fine
cioè quando il combustibile nucleare si
esaurisce il nucleo di queste stelle
massive non sopporta più il proprio peso
e inizia a contrarsi inizia a collassare
verso il centro occupando un volume
sempre più piccole acquistando densità
dissi me a meno che la massa non sia
troppo alta
nel qual caso si va a formare subito un
buco nero non è il nostro caso
questa contrazione a un certo punto si
arresta improvvisamente a causa di una
nuova forma di pressione che interviene
quando le particelle in particolare in
questo casi neutroni sono costretti a
stare troppo vicini gli uni agli altri e
quindi tendono a respingersi resistono
questo arresta la contrazione in modo
improvviso e questo produce un effetto
di rimbalzo per cui tutto il resto della
stella viene sparato via anche con
l'aiuto io non posso entrare nei
dettagli ma per essere corretti con
l'aiuto della spinta delle missioni di
neutrini dal nucleo non voglio entrare
questi dettagli
in poche parole abbiamo una tremenda
esplosione e questo fenomeno esplosivo
appunto la nostra supernova mentre
l'oggetto compatto che rimane al centro
ovvero presente sarebbe il nucleo
originario della stella appena esplosa è
la nostra stella di neutroni
il nome deriva dal fatto che a queste
densità così alte possiamo aspettarci
che in effetti la materia sia composta
principalmente di neutroni come scala di
massa e compattezza
è un po come concentrare tutto il nostro
sole entro una sferetta di appena 20 30
km cioè meno della distanza tra padova e
rovigo e questo porta a delle densità
spettacolari che potete immaginare che
addirittura superano la densità dei
nuclei atomici per dare un incontro
esempio un po più tangibile un
cucchiaino un cucchiaio di questa
materia peserebbe circa un miliardo di
tonnellate cioè più o meno quanto il
monte everest
le densità a che si raggiungono in
questi oggetti sono così alte che il
comportamento della materia e le stesse
forze fisiche le stesse forze
fondamentali sono realtà sconosciute e
non c'è modo di riprodurre queste
condizioni in un laboratorio sulla terra
in un certo senso le stelle di neutroni
sono il nostro laboratorio grazie al
quale abbiamo l'opportunità unica di
studiare il comportamento della materia
e più in generale le leggi della
fisica in queste condizioni estreme di
capire perché questo è il motivo per
questi neuroni sono oggetti così
interessanti e così preziosi
pensate cosa può succedere se due stelle
di neutroni arrivano interagire fra di
loro come le altre stelle anche questi
oggetti possono trovarsi un sistema
binario quindi trovarsi a interagire a
orbitare uno intorno all'altro a una
certa distanza interviene un altro
effetto fondamentale che è l'emissione
di onde gravitazionali dove forse avete
sentito parlare negli ultimi anni come
ci insegnano a scuola la gravità e si
manifesta con una forza che ha tra le
masse fra di loro ma se una massa si
sposta questo cambiamento l'informazione
che è cambiato qualcosa non si propaga
all'istante in tutto il resto dello
spazio circostante ma si propaga come
un'onda proprio nello spazio e nel tempo
e lo fa anche una certa velocità ben
precisa che è la velocità della luce
questo lo sappiamo grazie alla teoria
della relatività di einstein come
analogia visiva pensato di gettare il
sasso nell'acqua
questo genera delle onde che trasportano
con se l'informazione che a un certo
punto è successo qualcosa al centro c'è
stata una perturbazione se delle masse
si spostano cambiano queste genero onde
gravitazionali ovvero rimodulazioni
riconfigurazioni della forza di gravità
percepita le varie distanze
per effetto di questo cambiamento e per
esempio se io muovo la mano voi potreste
percepire in realtà impercettibile una
variazione della trazione di gravità
dovuta alla mia mano che ha cambiato
posizione ma non la sentirete
all'istante
per esempio chi si trova a 300 metri la
sentirà solo dopo un microsecondo che è
il tempo di propagazione dell'onda
gravitazionale che ho generato col mio
spostamento le onde gravitazionali come
le onde acustiche le onde radio per
esempio sono tutte conseguenza del fatto
che l'informazione non si sta propagando
all'istante ma c'è una velocità limite e
tutti questi tipi di onde oltre
all'informazione trasportano energia che
viene persa quindi spesa dalla sorge
nel caso di due stelle di neutroni in un
sistema binario queste modificano
periodicamente quello che chiamiamo il
campo gravitazionale in una maniera
fortissima emettono tantissima energia
in onde gravitazionali visto che
l'energia è sottratta dalle moto
orbitale
l'effetto è che gradualmente i due
oggetti perdono un momento angolare
senza che spiego i due oggetti trovo si
trovano sempre più vicini e questo è un
sistema che può evolvere in nello stesso
modo per milioni di anni o anche molto
di più quando finalmente arriviamo al
punto in cui le due stelle si toccano o
mail si scontrano per poi fondersi in un
unico oggetto ed è qui che viene il
bello perché potete immaginare qui si
scatena l'inferno potremmo dire abbiamo
delle energie coinvolte in questo
scontro straordinarie pazzesche e oltre
alle onde gravitazionali possiamo
aspettarci di vedere anche tantissima
emissione di luce in questo momento in
tutte le sue forme
quindi tutto lo spettro elettromagnetico
raggi gamma arges onde radio luce
ultravioletta visibile infrarossa una
specie di spettacolo pirotecnico del
cosmo e per decenni chi studia queste
cose livello teorico tra cui anch'io ci
siamo interrogati su quali tipi di
emissioni luminose potevamo aspettarci
in concomitanza di questo evento e due
in particolare sono molto rilevanti
la prima i gamma ray basta questi sono
lampi di raggi gamma luminosissimi di
breve durata che in realtà osserviamo
ormai a centinaia ogni anno e provengono
da galassie lontane
questi sono generati da potenti getti di
energia che la cui sorgente deve essere
per forza ultra compatta ea rotazione
molto rapida e guarda caso le
caratteristiche del nostro oggetto
risultato della fusione delle due stelle
è proprio ultra compatto ea rotazione
molto rapida quindi è un candidato per
produrre questi questi eventi numero due
la kg nova questo in realtà è stato
predetto a livello teorico a partire da
questo fatto
le altissime temperature e le altissime
concentrazioni di neutroni che si
ritrovano in questo scontro possono
accendere un nuovo tipo di reazione
nucleare è chiamato i processi r che
sono responsabili della produzione della
sintetizzazione di elementi molto
pesanti degli elementi più pesanti così
pesanti che non li troviamo neanche nel
al centro di stelle come il sole per
esempio e fra questi elementi c'è anche
loro così come il platino e così via
fino all uranio addirittura quindi
possiamo aspettarci che parte di questo
del materiale che nella violenza dello
scontro viene espulsa sia in effetti
composto questi elementi molto pesanti
come facciamo a verificarlo questi
elementi sono anche radioattivi e il
loro naturale decadimento riscalda il
materiale stesso e lo illumina
producendo questo segnale che è chiamato
appunto kg nova se vediamo questo
segnale sappiamo che c'è stata la
produzione di elementi pesanti in questo
sistema abbiamo quindi vari pezzi di un
puzzle abbiamo le onde gravitazionali
gamma ribas kg nova è altro che sono
tutti importanti poi anno porta
informazioni molto preziose presi
singolarmente ma per un quadro completo
dobbiamo metterli insieme tutti quanti
e questo è un caso perfetto per la
cosiddetta astrofisica multi messaggera
cioè basata su diversi canali di
osservazione indipendente in questo caso
luce e una gravitazionali e lo scontro
di due stelle di neutroni è sempre stato
considerato la sorgente multi ma esagera
per eccellenza il tipo di evento più
promettente in quello che è di fatto un
nuovo modo di fare astrofisica e bene
17 agosto 2017 c'è un paio di anni fa
abbiamo per la prima volta ha visto
deputato percepito rivelato uno di
questi scontri cosmici fra due stelle di
neutroni avvenuto a 130 milioni di anni
luce di distanza che vuol dire anche 130
milioni di anni fa cioè quando sulla
terra siano dinosauri i segnali prodotti
sono stati il hanno viaggiato per tutto
questo tempo indisturbati per arrivare
poi finalmente da noi è l'immagine che
faccio vedere adesso che prendete forse
la più bella immagine vera di questo
evento una vera immagine presa dal
telescopio hubble
qui vediamo la galassia che ha ospitato
il nostro evento il nostro scontro
cosmico e il puntino luminoso in alto a
sinistra quello arancione lì è dove lo
scontro è avvenuto e quella luce
arancione è proprio la luce della kg
nova di cui ho parlato prima
e qui devo ammettere che anche per noi
che facciamo questo lavoro e non ci
possiamo stupire più di tanto di alcune
cose vedere questa immagine così
chiaramente vedere la kg nova con i
nostri occhi è stato molto emozionante e
la campagna osservativa per seguire
questo evento è stata senza precedenti
ha combinato insieme i rivelatori di
onde gravitazionali che sono live negli
stati uniti virgo in italia ne abbiamo
uno dei tre che sono al momento attivi è
proprio in italia vicino pisa e
dall'altra tutta la potenza di fuoco su
scala mondiale in termini dei migliori
telescopi da terra e dallo spazio anche
in tutte le bande quindi alta energia
hicks gamma i radiotelescopi tutto
quanto e ci è andata anche bene perché
non solo abbiamo visto questo evento ma
in un colpo solo
abbiamo messo a segno abbiamo catturato
tutti gli elementi principali che da
decenni speravamo di poter osservare e
poter studiare e abbiamo imparato
moltissimo prima di tutto questi eventi
esistono capitano con una certa
frequenza che possiamo stimare anche da
un solo evento e possiamo iniziare a
farsi un'idea
abbiamo visto un lampo di raggi gamma
provenire da lì
quindi abbiamo confermato ciò che
sospettavamo che questi lampi possono
essere prodotti da questi scontri cosmos
indirettamente abbiamo capito qualcosa
in più sul comportamento della materia
a queste densità altissime perché questo
è un effetto sulla forma dell'onda
gravitazionale e su tutto sul materiale
viene espulso eccetera eccetera e non
ultimo abbiamo visto la kg nova quindi
abbiamo confermato la produzione di
elementi pesanti in questi sistemi
trovando neanche molti di più di quelli
che ci aspettavamo per esempio tornando
a loro si stima che questo evento abbia
prodotto equivalente in oro di qualcosa
come 10 volte se non 100 volte la massa
del nostro pianeta
questo è il 100 mila miliardi di
miliardi di tonnellate di cui parlavo
all'inizio
al di là di questo numero spettacolare
la cosa veramente importante a livello
scientifico e che tutti gli elementi
pesanti anche che abbiamo sulla terra
d'alloro in poi vengono anche e forse in
gran parte dallo scontro di stelle di
neutroni avvenuta in passato nella
nostra galassia
quindi c'è una certa probabilità che
l'oro che costituisce i nostri gioielli
venga stessa il prodotto in questo modo
qui e chiudo sull'evento facendo vedere
questo filmato che riassume in modo
artistico le varie fasi emissione di
onde gravitazionali nell'ultima le
ultime orbite lo scontro è la produzione
del getto che poi porterà al lampo di
raggi gamma
subito dopo l'illuminazione di questi di
questo materiale espulso la kg nuova
eliminazione radioattiva e infine
ulteriore radiazione che è prodotta dal
fatto che questo oggetto comunque si sta
propagando nel mezzo interstellare e
quindi illumina il fronte di questo
oggetto continua illuminarsi con questo
primo fondamentale evento abbiamo aperto
l'astrofisica multi messaggera è un
nuovo capitolo della scienza che
sicuramente nei prossimi anni porterà
tante sorprese
una scoperta scientifica di tale portata
che sicuramente è la più importante a
cui abbia avuto la fortuna di
partecipare offre un ottimo esempio di
come osserva
dal cielo possa capitarci vedere cose
straordinarie
da una parte questo ci permette anzi ci
costringe a qualche modo uscire dai
limiti della nostra stessa immaginazione
l'universo fa quello che vuole e lo
vediamo in tutta la sua gloria in tutta
la sua complessità
dall'altra guardando questi fenomeni
molto lontani possiamo realtà imparare
qualcosa di nuovo su le leggi della
natura e del mondo in cui viviamo anche
e soprattutto in regimi che non siamo in
regime quindi condizioni che non siamo
in grado di riprodurre con esperimenti
terrestri
tutto questo è possibile se abbiamo la
capacità solo se abbiamo la capacità di
osservare i vari fenomeni con i nostri
strumenti sempre più potenti ma anche e
soprattutto se abbiamo la capacità di
capirli interpretarli trasformando un
mucchio di segnale complicati in una
descrizione coerente in una frase è
questo il senso di fare astrofisica la
storia dell'umanità è fatta di curiosità
ed è fatta di scoperte alcune delle
quali nate proprio dal nostro impulso
naturale alzare gli occhi al cielo
notturno e cercare di spiegarne le
meraviglie è quotato questa nostra
natura credo che lo sviluppo la scienza
e dell'astrofisica in particolare sia
stato semplicemente inevitabile e sono
convinto che dal nostro piccolo angolo
di universo continueremo sempre a
esplorare a conoscere ea goderci lo
spettacolo grazie
[Applauso]